in kindergarten they taught us that the  primary colors were red blue and yellow  but that was a lie when you print  something it starts with white paper  then makes a bunch of little dots using  cyan magenta and yellow  to create new colors by subtracting  light from the reflective surface  but computer screens are black and emit  their own light thanks to the 23 year  old isaac newton we know that combining  red  green and blue light creates white light  makes sense because you're adding the  peaks of the visible spectrum together  modern displays have millions of  individual pixels that change the  intensity of red green and blue light  to render the images that you're looking  at right now the truth is that cmy are  the primary subtractive colors  and rgb are the primary additive colors  and your teachers also lied about that  apple that fell on isaac newton's head